You
might call
this The Godfather meets Washington.
Instead of five warring mob families.
It's a group of Republican lawmakers
from across their caucuses
political spectrum
trying to avoid a catastrophic
debt default.
CNN reports the talks
between the so-called five families
and the House Republican leadership
are in their early stages.
The goal,
some sort of consensus on the debt limit.
What the lawmakers
and the leadership
hope is that they can force Democrats
to back off their calls
to raise the debt ceiling
with no spending cuts.
CNN's David McKenzie and Melanie Sloan
join our conversation.
So Kevin McCarthy
not afraid of The Godfather.
He gets calls to five disparate groups
within the Republican family,
the five families
And the idea is this is hard.
If you want to propose
spending cuts in conjunction
with the debt limit,
that means
you've got to put them on paper.
So you're trying to get
the most conservative members
to agree with the more moderate members.
And so the strategy here for Kevin
McCarthy is really twofold.
He wants to first show
that Republicans
can get 218 votes for any spending plan
because one of the chief
criticisms of Republicans has been
they can't negotiate among themselves.
They could barely elect
Kevin McCarthy as speaker.
Well, let alone
be negotiating with the White House here.
So they're trying to strengthen
their negotiating hand by showing,
hey, we do have a plan,
we can come to agreement
and we can do this.
And the second part of the strategy
for Kevin
McCarthy is
he wants to have an inclusive process
with these so-called five families,
a godfather
reference there
that I will say not all Republicans
love that reference,
but McCarthy wants to show
that it's
not just going to be leadership driven.
And that's
because he knows
that this is going to be a make
or break moment for his speakership.
There is the power to oust him
at any given moment.
So he is trying to sort of
thread the needle here
among the various wings of his party.
But it's going to be a lot
easier said than done.
And then if
and when they come to that agreement,
they still have to negotiate
with the Democrats.
And so let's just let's just go.
You see them
up, up on the screen
there, Garret Graves as a top McCarthy,
I call him the leadership family.
He's representing
the leadership in there.
Dusty Johnson,
is the chairman of what they call
the Main Street Caucus.
Patrick McHenry,
the Financial Services
Committee chairman.
David Joyce, Republican Governors Group,
Scott Perry, the Freedom Caucus.
They tend to be
the more conservative members
so far in this piece ever.
This is Dusty
Johnson is the level of trust
and engagement
within the five families
that I've not seen in the previous
four years.
We're working really well together.
Ralph Norman
of South Carolina, among those
who was not going to vote
for Kevin McCarthy back in the beginning,
who ultimately did.
We're trying to get to the framework
we all want buy in.
There's a sense of that's the group
putting something out another group
put something out.
They don't want that.
They don't want to have
you know, you propose this.
She proposes that.
The question is,
you can start a conversation.
Can you get to the finish line? Right.
I would expect optimism
from some of those key negotiators there.
And ultimately, Speaker
McCarthy is speaking to a concern
that was voiced
by Republicans
that power needed to be decentralized
means that
everyone should have
a role in these key negotiations.
But the problem for Republicans
is going to be landing
on what exactly these cuts will be.
This is a party that has,
I think, like
like to branded
the brand themselves on austerity.
But then when you get to the nitty gritty
and actually naming the programs
we just have not seen,
I think, a little political willingness
to go that far.
And Republicans
get a lot more fiscally conservative
when there's a Democratic president.
Just a funny coincidence in town.
The Democrats
believe they have the upper hand here.
This is the Senate majority leader, Chuck
Schumer, saying,
I dare you put it in writing.
We have a clear position.
Do it clean.
Do it without brinksmanship, do it
without this risk of hostage
taking where things could blow up.
He will not even say
what he wants to cut.
And I'll tell you why
he can't pass a plan with cuts.
His hard right
will demand the kind of deepest cuts
that his more mainstream
Republicans won't vote for.
Senator Schumer is not wrong
about the complications in the House
Republican family.
Here's my question, though.
Can he keep the Democrats?
Can it
can he keep the Democrats
who in Trump states like
Jon Tester
from Montana,
Sherrod Brown in Ohio,
who have to run in 2024?
Can he he keep them from saying
let's do this clean?
We don't want any kind of spending cuts?
Well, that's one thing
that we're starting to see already,
whether it's Senator Joe Manchin
who has said that
he's fine with negotiating
and trying to encourage
President Biden to negotiate,
even though the vast majority
of Democrats,
which is probably what
Majority Leader Schumer
speaking to do, want to do this clean.
And also economists
whether they work for the US chamber
or elsewhere, have also said
they think it should be
a clean increase versus
tethering it to any kind of cuts
in terms of like Republicans
and what they in the past
have said they want to cut.
There's a long history there.
I mean, Paul Ryan, when he was speaker,
very much
wanted to turn Medicare
into a voucher system.
And Republicans in the past
have said over and over
they want to cut entitlements
which include
Social Security and Medicare.
So I know that Speaker McCarthy says
that isn't on the table this time,
but that's also why
President Biden feels like he has
his upper
hand is because of this long
list of history
and trying to push Republicans
to the name. Exactly.
Very specifically what they want.
And yet it is not that far
down the road where both Medicare
and Social Security
do need solvency help.
They just do this as Senator Mike
Rounds, a Republican who says,
if we're having this political fight,
we're not going to get to the substance,
which
is a golden
opportunity and in a bipartisan way
to put
Social Security on a long term plan
that would make it better in the future
than what it is today.
And to assure its longevity.
But you do that by managing it.
You do that
by actually talking about it and not,
you know, doing doing dog calls.
Every time somebody says
let's try to address managing it.
He's blaming
the president for dog calls now.
But, you know,
the only way to do this in the past,
anyway, has been a bipartisan commission.
Right.
But but you have to go into it
with an open mind, meaning,
you know,
Democrats would have to go into it, that
maybe some programs
would be trimmed a little bit,
but Republicans would have to go into it
thinking maybe we need new revenues
to pay for all of this.
We don't have that situation right now.
And with the president highlighting
this so much, is it
am I dumb to believe
that this is gonna have to wait
until after the next
presidential election?
Oh, if then you know this.
This is a conversation
that comes up from time to time
about how to make Medicare
and Social Security
long lasting and strong,
which I think everyone agrees
they want it to be.
But that is not an easy fix.
It's not the kind of thing
that can be negotiated
between now and June
when the debt ceiling comes up.
And there is sort of a wasteland
of bipartisan commissions
that have
tried to
to find an answer to this challenge.
But
as the senator says,
you know,
the middle of a partizan fight
about the debt
ceiling is probably not the place
where that's going to happen.
And the president told Speaker McCarthy,
I'll talk to you about spending cuts,
but only after you raise
the debt ceiling.
Is there any way
the five families can agree on that.
Keep it as two separate approaches.
I mean, we'll see.
That's what
they're trying to figure out right now.
I do think that the goal right now
is to put up a plan
that would raise the debt
ceiling in exchange
for some spending cuts.
But like I said, putting that to
paper is a lot harder.
And putting your face
in front of these cuts,
the potentially popular programs,
it can be difficult
for some of these moderates to swallow.
And whether they realize it
or not,
John Reiff,
restructuring, reforming
entitlement programs,
that ultimately is a translation
to getting rid
of Social Security and Medicare.
Whether they're not,
they're clear on that yet.
That's where it leans.